[Music]
let's get it so keep yourself keep
yourself the best shot you're giving
yourself you're giving yourself the best
shot you got to get so no what you going
to get S never some Keep Your Best Shot
don't out get got to go reach out and
get you just go reach out and get you
get out
for we try to get you got to go we try
to get you just go we try to get you
just get get out get on
it game over but they give him all the
street co little kitty in the gutter
with the bloody nose undercover buy
doesn't even beat the headines the head
R so bu hasn't got an anle look and came
from Z everybody with B the power grows
and grows let's get it
[Music]